the fans have lined up for the bts
concert since early this morning we have
sasha loftus out live with a look at
what's going on in all the bts madness
hi sasha
hey there vanessa yes it's about three
hours until that concert that bts
concert here at allegion stadium but
fans are already lining up in droves to
see it you can see the road behind me
here we're at polaris just north of
russell and it is already backed up now
some traffic notes here this has turned
into a one-way street as everyone heads
out here to the stadium you can see
there are lanes you kind of have to weed
through a lot of people as you can also
see are a little bit confused that this
is a one-way street so if you're driving
in this area just be mindful of that now
there are also some closures around the
rest of this area hacienda is close on
the eastbound side at valley view also
closures on russell at the i-15 south
dean martin southbound along the i-15 is
a little slow going as well and it is
still early it's only going to get more
backed up as we get closer to that 7 30
start time for tonight's concert also
keep in mind of course when that concert
ends things will of course pick back up
again so if you can maybe avoid this
area for the rest of the night if you're
not heading out to this bts concert